I have a blindfold on I'm completely
blind I can't see a damn thing now how
am I going to work the board what
can't even hear yeah I'm ready I'm
blindfolded is everyone blindfolded Fred
I am yes Robin yes are you a good
looking woman mystery guess uh yeah well
no and so I guess the questioning goes
to me all right go ahead mystery guest
would we know you from television
I reckon oh I reckon that's a Southern
accent okay how could you know who it is
are you currently in a series
mystery guess is you're Series in the
top ten
I reckon yeah
I bet it's George Clooney no let Fred
keep playing I'll bet you you're right
yeah
all right is that right take your mask
off whoa